One of the things that I've thought,
this is a bit of a tangent,
but I'll move back to the mortal afterwards.
See,
I really liked the psycho analyst and I liked the idea that you have a psyche
that's inside of you and that that is structured in partly consciously and in
part unconsciously.
There's something about that that's really cool and I've learned a lot from the
psychoanalyst,
but you know,
there is a funny consequence of thinking the way they think and you do think the
way they think,
even if you don't know it.
Like we tend to think that a lot of us has inside our head.
You know,
that's the psyche model basically.
But the more I've practiced as a clinical psychologist,
the last,
I've actually been convinced that that's true.
So I could say,
well,
let's say I want to know about your personality.
We think,
well,
I want to know you.
I want to know about your subjectivity.
I didn't want to know what's inside of you,
but that isn't actually what you do.
Want to know if,
if,
if you're doing clinical work,
say with someone you want to know,
did they have any friends?
That's really important because if you're miserable and anxious and badly placed
in life and misbehaving,
one of the reasons that all of that can occur is because you don't have any
friends.
You don't know anyone.
And that's not something that's inside you.
It's,
it's you localized in a broader sphere.
And then you might say,
well,
do you have job and well,
let's talk about the job.
Do you actually make enough money with your job?
Is it satisfying for you in any way?
Are you bullied all the time?
When you're at work?
Does it provoke anxiety?
Is it a career that allows you to go somewhere?
Are you overworked?
Well,
but let's start with just the first question.
Do you have a job?
Well,
if the answer to that is no,
you have a serious problem and that would enough might be to depress you and
make you anxious and hopeless and nihilistic and all of those things.
And you could say,
well,
you're not reacting very well to not having a job.
But that's kind of a foolish objection,
even though some of it might be true.
One problem is,
is that you're not reacting very well to not having a job.
But another problem is that you don't have a job and that actually constitutes a
problem,
right?
You don't get to eat.
You don't have a place to live.
Those aren't psychological problems precisely,
even though a psychological problem could make it worse.
Well,
are you as educated as you should be?
That's another question.
How do you handle drugs and alcohol?
Are they taking you down a bad pathway?
You know?
Um,
what about intimate relationships?
Do you have one?
You have a plan for one or they,
is that a never ending series of catastrophes or something that you avoid
completely.
That's a big problem.
And maybe people don't,
aren't attracted to you for one reason or another.
And you can think about that as a psychological problem,
but it's an interpersonal problem.
And the degree to which that's a psychological problem is,
is certainly an unspecified.
When you first begin to talk to somebody,
what about your family?
Do you have a family?
Because it's hard to be in the world all by yourself.
That's sure.
It makes things a lot more stressful.
Even though having a family can also be extraordinarily stressful,
you know,
do you have plans to have children?
How are you doing with your parents?
Do you get along with your siblings?
You know,
all of that.
All of that to me is more fundamental and it's outside of you.
Those are elements of your experience more broadly conceptualized more than they
are objects of your psychology or of your internal experience.
You know,
it's sort of like
while a person is,
uh,
is it is a creature that exists at multiple levels of analysis,
right?
Something might go wrong with you at a cellular level,
so maybe you're born with a genetic abnormality,
so something's wrong with you molecularly or you have something wrong with a
major organ.
Or maybe there's something wrong with you psychologically,
or maybe you're in a pathological family or maybe you're stuck in a pathological
social system and,
and figuring out what's,
why you're suffering means going up and down those different levels.
Trying to specify the appropriate level for analysis.
And also the appropriate level for intervention.
And for me as a,
as I've said,
even though I'm a great admirer of the psychoanalysts and I do things like dream
analysis,
which I really find you an incredibly useful and enlightening the first,
the fundamental level of analysis is,
well what's your experience structured like?
Exactly.
And that isn't localized in you.
Now the behaviorists do that too because it's one of the things I really liked
about the behavioral approach to psychotherapy.
It's very,
very concrete and practical.
It's like they'll say,
well,
there are certain things that you need to have in order to live properly and
maybe you don't have the skills or the wherewithal where with all to accumulate
them and we'll break them down into tiny little pieces and you'll practice.
So for example,
with someone who doesn't have any friends,
then you do a micro analysis of their social skills,
say and maybe an analysis of the kinds of anxiety that are stopping them from
going out and meeting people.
And then you address those things practically one by one.
You try to get the person to have some friends,
he tried to figure out how they can establish an intimate relationship.
You see if you can help them sort out their family,
you do what you can about their employment.
And a lot of that's only tangentially related to really in some sense to the
structure of their psyche.
But one of the things you'll see if you work as a clinician or as a counselor is
that most of the time people come and see you because they have problems,
not because they have psychological problems and those things are not that easy
to distinguish.
You know,
it's sort of the psychoanalytic idea,
sort of like,
well if you just start your act together,
everything would work out for you.
It's like,
yeah,
okay,
there's some truth in that,
but,
but you know,
if you're 55 years old and you've just been laid off work
and maybe through no fault of your own,
it isn't obvious how much getting your act together,
it's going to help you find another job because the,
the actual problem that you're facing may have relatively little to do with you.
And that would especially be the case if you're maybe on the bottom half of the
intelligence distribution,
for example.
And so it isn't as easy for you just to go out and pick up new skills at the
drop of a hat.
You know?
Again,
that gets harder as you get older because your Iq actually declines quite
substantially as you get older.
That that working or the the fluid intelligence part anyways,
exercise can keep that at bay.
By the way,
it's the best way to keep that at bay.